I was in a conversation with a bunch of
people
who was I talking about this with
about like Dan Bilzerian that guy that
does all the um
flying around
with the chicks
like I was thinking about that and I was
thinking about how that's quote unquote
every guy's fantasy right to just have
[__] you know
10 chicks around you know the Hugh
Hefner thing right like
we just got 10 chicks and you just
around they're around and you're just
always around them and all that [__] and
I was thinking about like if that had
that choice like like
like here's the thing dude having sex
with a bunch of different women sure
that's I understand that want that's
cool and that's can be hot and it's
great whatever
but
what's up with this guy though what's up
with
and the guy seems happy and [__] and no
knock on the dude the guy's [__]
doing what he wants to do but
you this guy's not doing that he's like
you gotta oh you gotta be on a plane
with them for six hours
like that's the thing that I don't get
like this guy's always chilling with him
and I'm not saying it's not fun to be
around 10 chicks I'm saying it's not fun
to be around 10 thoughts
it's not it's it's
not and and maybe there's something
wrong with me okay
like
but like if Dan and he would never
because I'm boring as [__] but if he
asked me to be like yo we're going to
New York get on the private jet these 12
thoughts are going to come with us
I would be like oh bro I can't I can't
go dude
and then he would be like but look at
the girls and I would be like yeah but
they're gonna talk and stuff
what are I'd say yeah but what are we
gonna talk about
what are we gonna say
I get one I get having sex with all of
the girls is fun
but then they're all at your house
and they're like
where did I put my and you're like oh I
I don't know
and the girl's like you're always losing
[__] and then the other one's like well
um hello people just think I should be a
comedian because like I'm always losing
stuff and I'm always just commenting on
it and then other girl's like you should
be
and they just have a shirt on
and I gotta be like yeah you should be a
comedian or what what or what what do I
say to that
if I'm in that situation I go like this
hey hey hey hey
no
I just don't I don't get it I don't get
that life I wish
and I like I said no knock on the
[__] dude and the chicks are there
having fun
he's having fun that's great you know
it's it's like me I don't want to
[__] go to a football game you know
I'm never gonna look at another guy
running with a ball and [__] actually
be like [__]
[__] like I I for what
he went to the [__] place he went to
the end
oh
see he doesn't even know who I am I
don't give a [__]
I get busted and coming but hanging
I get busting and common
but hanging
I get busted and common
but on a plane to New York
hahaha
I just don't I don't know I don't get it
maybe like I think a lot of guys I I
think a lot of guys would not choose
that
right I want to know what kind of guy
would go on that trip
the girls are [__] hot dude they're
all real hot not you know I'm not going
to be one of those guys
here's what's annoying the guy's like
those girls aren't even hot dude shut up
dude shut the [__] up
those girls are all hot
girls are hot girls yeah dude the guy
who's like
you know I don't care if the boobs
aren't big if they're fake nah
dude shut up
no knock on small boobs that [__]
small boobs can be great but dude just
because they're fake doesn't mean
they're bad
yeah girls who got the [__] too much
too much of the [__] nah not for me and
you're in your [__] cubicle just fat
you know
just [__]
hot girls are hot girls okay my point is
being on a plane with them 12 of them
when they're just doing Instagram
stories
jumping out
I'm gonna this is how I'm having a
conversation okay cool
[Music]
then I'm just like this
Birds what what are you doing here oh
dude thoughts
you know
Rock what are you doing here why are you
why are you jump out of the plane oh
girl up there said she should be a
comedian and all of her friends think
that she should be a comedian
[Laughter]
she said she's the silliest girl in the
world
Brock what are you doing down here oh
the girl up there said that one time she
met Tyga's brother
yeah you did the right thing